you already know he sports a superior
mustache and is blessed with a nose for
news but there are a few things you
might not know about San Diego's most
beloved news person this is the untold
truth of Ron Burgundy
of course there could be no Ron Burgundy
without Will Ferrell the actor and
comedian who enjoyed a triumphant
seven-year run on Saturday Night Live
from 1995 to 2002 what is it mr.
tarkanian oh thank you that's exactly
the response I'm looking for Ferrell has
left his indelible mark on a number of
films and television shows including
memorable turns and Zoolander stranger
than fiction in the office to name just
a few
he's a master at creating huge bombastic
characters and he'll do just about
anything for a laugh he can also infuse
roles with heart and emotional heft as
he demonstrated in the 2003 comedy elf a
man of many talents Ferrell also created
the comedy website Funny or Die with
frequent collaborator Adam McKay what's
more he served as an executive producer
on shows like eastbound and down and
succession looks like Ron Burgundy
Ferrell really gets around released in
2004 anchorman The Legend of Ron
Burgundy is one of the most eminently
quotable movies of all time the now
classic film tells the story of you
guessed it Ron Burgundy a local
newscaster in San Diego his world is
suddenly turned upside down by the
addition of newscaster Veronica
Corningstone
played by Christina Applegate Ron is
instantly smitten and he has a really
interesting way of showing it you stay
classy San Diego and thanks for stopping
by but mainly stay classy thanks for
stopping by stay classy I'm Ron Burgundy
Farrell's performance makes the film
work seamlessly and the end result is a
truly uproarious and original comedy in
fact the bloody anchorman fight might be
one of the oddest sequences ever
committed to celluloid yeah
to man in the heart I saw that if you
thought the original anchorman was crazy
it's got nothing on the sequel released
in 2013 the film finds Ron and Veronica
working at a huge network in New York
City Harrison Ford plays newscaster Mack
Tannen who announces his retirement and
reveals he wants to give his job to
Veronica rather than Ron this
development immediately drives a rift
between the couple Burgundy temporarily
leaves his wife and child to join the
first 24-hour news network alongside his
original team facing off against younger
more popular anchorman Jack lime
portrayed by James Marsden there's even
a second anchorman fight which is bigger
and better than the first we'd also be
remiss not to mention the insane subplot
that finds Ron adopting a shark named
Dobby well it never quite reaches the
comedic heights of the original it's
still a worthwhile film especially since
it fully embraces its own ridiculousness
check this out yes sir this was fun we
shot this over two weeks in Prague Wow
Ron Burgundy is based on a real person
and his name is Mort scrim the
Philadelphia born newsman spent decades
delivering the news in 2009 a Crim was
even inducted into the broadcast
pioneers of Philadelphia's Hall of Fame
but what makes him so ripe for satire
well you have to understand that I was a
typical traditional 1972 male chauvinist
anchor in 2013 Ferrell admitted he was
inspired by crimson general look and
Krim seems to have enjoyed the imitation
telling USA Today any good parody takes
a grain of truth and exaggerated sit for
the big screen people ask me if I'm
offended at all and I say not in the
least as he told the Australian morning
show wake up in 2013 you know I think
anchorman 1 was a very good parody of
how it was back in the 70s but no love
for anchorman 2 the legend continues
interesting you just never know when a
little bit of Ron will enter your life
during the promotional period for
anchorman 2 in 2012 Burgundy made a few
memorable appearances on conan night in
and night out you guys get it done oh
thank you he's also no stranger to the
world of sports contributing his special
brand of madness to both the 2014
Olympics and a Los Angeles Kings game in
2019 bailey brought me a true media
maven Ron Burgundy has also appeared in
a series of commercials for dodge I've
told them a hundred times they can't
dance in here bunch of dirty dances last
but not least he appeared at the Comedy
Central Roast of Justin Bieber in 2015
some real clever writing great energy
over there whatever the occasion it's
always a pleasure to see Ron again in
the summer of 2019 Will Ferrell really
ramped up his Ron Burgundy appearances
staging an unexpected late-night take
over on one random Thursday six
different shows listed a surprise guest
in their credits and that gas turned out
to be none other than Ron Burgundy on
Thursday August 8th burgundy appeared on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert The
Late Late Show with James Corden The
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon Conan
Late Night with Seth Meyers and Jimmy
Kimmel Live Burgundy was ostensibly
making the rounds to hone his so-called
comedy routine which as you've probably
guessed is terrible we got me a Shawn
Mendes fans here tonight don't like him
never have all these appearances helped
promote the second season of the Ron
Burgundy podcast and you can bet we've
been tuning in we just can't get enough
of his incisive worldview
why are tiny refrigerators called mini
bars hotels I don't call bars giant
refrigerator check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]